my name's graeme zabel i uh
i work for divo team which is a
i.t consultancy
um
prior to that i worked at barclays for
10 years so there's a bit of a barclays
theme tonight i worked very closely with
barry
um so i've known barry for a long time
and for the last five of those 10 years
at barclays i was leading the devops
transformation in the investment bank
so when you said head of devops i was
no you didn't i applied for your job
though actually
anyway
before you joined yes
um death of devops slightly
controversial i'll put a little little
footnote in there as we know it
this is a bit of a mashup of several
presentations i give one on devops a
scale the evolution of devops devops in
the enterprise
when
we talk about devops devops in the
enterprise is a whole different ballgame
to uh devops at startups and if you
attend meetups a lot and listen to
startups
i got it's very dispiriting because
you're saying oh we're using kubernetes
we're using aws we're doing all these
cool things and you think i'm working at
this big company we're not doing any of
that stuff
and and you kind of think we're you know
at a big company you're 10 years behind
what's going on but actually i think the
startups are probably five years ahead
of most people and most people are are
really doing devops in a different way
especially for a big company than than
what be social might be doing
um this is a model i developed at
barclays we i use it now we use it with
clients at my current company i'm going
to talk through it i'm sure most of you
are familiar with devops already so i'm
going to talk through it very quickly
because i want to overlay on top of this
model
the way i see devops evolving and why i
think
the current way we're doing devops in
big companies is is really finished
so i'm just going to walk through
through these things quickly we start
start with business requirements and
tasks so this is the agile it part of
devops
you put tasks on a kanban board
developers take those tasks write codes
they check it into a source code control
system ideally it's code reviewed etc
and that code is automatically built by
a build tool it always runs automated
testing and that's your ci cycle
you collect metrics out of those out of
the ci cycle
um apologies have been going fast but i
this is not the heart of what i want to
speak about
we if if code is built automated tests
are all green you've essentially got
shippable code i think that's one of the
tenants of devops that you're
continually building code if it's green
it's shippable it might not be shippable
into production but it's certainly
shippable into other environments
and then this is sort of the newer part
of devops i think the ci part of devops
is very mature in most organizations i
think it's we've been doing it for
probably over a decade over over
since before devops was a thing
um
infest the the ops side of the cd side
is much much less
mature so we're writing infrastructure's
code now is particularly for in the
cloud using things like terraform and
ansible
we still if we're if you're in a large
enterprise you still have to have
service management you still have to
deal with probably servicenow so that
you're you cannot deploy into production
without your requisite uh requests and
and changes approved
um
so
when you've got infrastructure as code
you're building your infrastructure an
automated way you're building your code
in an automated way to produce artifacts
you're interacting ideally with a
service management tool in an automated
way and you put all these things
together and you've got continuous
deployment and you deploy into
it could be a cloud environment
it could be an on-prem environment etc
once it's in that environment you want
to be monitoring it so we talk a lot
more recently especially about
continuous observability or
observability driven design so you're
building apps that are observable
and then across the entire pipeline
you've got
security concerns you're you're
concerned about the security within your
code within your docker images
potentially you want to make sure people
aren't bitcoin aren't um bit mining in
your in your aws accounts etc and then
there's also collaboration across this
whole model so chat ops we've talked
about chat ops today so essentially
that that is a devops model i think it's
pretty common it's very much like the
the sideways figure of eight model a lot
of you most of you have seen
now um we take that model
and then on top of that we put the
evolution of devops so devops as as
we're talking about a lot this year it's
been it's about 10 years old
i think 10 years ago we started with
shadow devops so what does that mean it
really it was really a ground-up
phenomenon
developers started
there was cruise control at the very
beginning uh they started wanting to
build their code in an automated way we
were starting to write unit tests we
wanted to have a lot more automated
testing
um so so this came from the ground up
developers started saying i need a ci
tool i'm going to bring one in i'm going
to start using
cruise control for example
i need to store my artifacts somewhere
so i'm going to i'm going to spin up a
nexus server and and i need to measure
my code so i'm going to spin up a sonar
cube server so we all these teams
from the ground up were spinning up all
this infrastructure and still at a at
the c-suite level no one had even heard
of devops no one no one knew what dev
also was i think five years ago when i
joined the cto team and i talked to our
cto about devops he didn't he had he
didn't know the term they'd never heard
of devops so it was still five years ago
very new at the c-suite level at the
senior management level no one knew what
devops was and i think then about five
years ago
the enterprise woke up and and the sort
of the c-suite people started to say we
need to do devops we need to do agile um
and so and they said oh look you know i
started looking around at all their
development community what they were
doing and they're going wow there's a
lot of devops going on here we need to
control it we need to centralize this
stuff we need to get central tools we
need to um
you know we've got vendor sprawl we've
got all kinds of vendors we're dealing
with
so
we we started um
getting this this enterprise devops
model
and if you look at this model you you've
got confluence jira most companies are
using confluence jira you've got team
city jenkins we saw on other slides
bamboo
um
so you've got sona type nexus
artifactories artifact management
systems all kinds of deployment
different ways of deploying your code
might be um xl deploy jenkins openshift
cloudify
you've got integration of servicenow
you've got all kinds of deployment
environments mostly still on-prem at
this time five years ago
a plethora of mana of monitoring tools
dozens of different monitoring tools and
you overlay this whole
tool suite onto a devops model
and you've got all these issues so
you've got on-prem devops on-prem
infrastructure
centralized devops teams
poor cost transparency so to give an
example at barclays
we had no we we knew we were using team
city we knew we were a team city shop
we didn't realize how many team city
instances we were running until we
started counting them and we found out
we had 120 team city instances spread
out across the bank
120 team city instances if you think
about it
if it takes and it takes two hours say
to upgrade a team city instance
two hours times 120 is 240 hours that's
six six man weeks of work every time
team city puts out a new instance a new
um version of their of their software
which they were doing every three to six
months so every time they put out a new
version of their software you've got six
man weeks of work to keep your state up
to date
um we had
close i think close to 40
artifact repositories most mostly nexus
so that means we have 40 copies of log4j
40 copies of every kind of library that
you can have and most of these in fact
all of these instances had an open door
to the outside world so there was no
security scanning no vulnerability
scanning etc
um so
just massive waste because you're
essentially storing a lot of these
third-party artifacts 40 times at least
40 times and then multiple versions of
those things
you so multi-vendor multi-tool as i
mentioned the upgrades and maintenance
it was a big big nightmare really and
then
i think the last point
multiple integrations so all of these
tools had to integrate with everything
else so people say jenkins oh yeah we've
got a hundred different plugins that
work with jenkins well that is not a bit
of a code smell or you know do you
really need a hundred plug-ins for a
tool
because jenkins is trying to integrate
with everything else that's in this
model
and i think when you have this
senior managers and the c-suite people
are still looking at development saying
i don't get it you guys are all raving
about devops this is this looks
ridiculous this is expensive you want me
to have a central devops team you're
asking for 10 terabytes of storage for
all your nexus instances and
it
i think at this point the benefits of
devops were still not being realized
so um
let me skip that um so
devops is a service this for me as i'm
seeing is the next evolution of devops
it's really cloud-based it's it's moving
off of prem
it's devops as a service you get
excellent cost transparency you know
month by month you get a bill you know
exactly how much you're paying you get
these
highly integrated tool chains
no infrastructure evergreen software you
don't have to worry about maintenance or
upgrades and everything is highly
modular
so that's i've got git lab i'm using as
an icon there
a lot of you probably heard the term get
ops it was mentioned tonight
we're using git lab with one of our
clients it's an incredible tool it does
everything it does your code
repositories it does your building your
testing it does your um your artifact
storage your deployments and it even is
trying to get into the service
management space where servicenow is
it's trying to get into the jira space
by using its own kanban boards etc
so here you just have one tool
this is the same on aws you've got um an
entire if you're on aws you've got your
entire code
code uh your devops pipelines with your
code commit code build code deploy tools
cloudformation etc
azure azure same thing they've got azure
devops google cloud has the same
google tools
um so how many people here use jenkins
quite a few anyone
uh yeah no one works for cloudbees i
hope
and i've asked this question and big
audiences how many people use jenkins
more than half the hands go up how many
people love jenkins most of the hands
stay up
there's no there's no jenkins in any of
these models there's no there's no
jenkins in in azure or um or aws or in
the gitlab in the get ops model
i was getting emails recently um from
cloud b saying stay tuned next week we
have an incredible announcement and
indeed it's got a huge industry and
implications
um you know it turns out cloudbees is
merging with electric cloud you're
caring yeah and
um
you know i i
and as you know i've mentioned already
that that jenkins has a hundred
different plug-ins but do we really want
tools with 100 plugins when these tools
don't have any plugins because they all
just work together
so
really for me the death of devops i
think
as i said earlier it's not you know you
look at the startups and what they're
doing you think well these guys are
doing really cool stuff and
obviously devops is going to be around
for a long time but i think devops in
the enterprise will change and will
change a lot
and one one last slide i have
this i've kind of stolen a little bit
from the there's a good website if you
haven't seen it devops topologies.com
and they have all these different models
of how devops can work in a large
company
this is really this i made this one up
based on theirs
again in enterprise devops if you you
know we were trying to do devops at
barclays and
yet you can you can start using the
tooling you can start changing your
processes changing your culture a bit
but you still had to go to the database
team when you needed to spin up a
database you still had to go to the
networking team when you needed some
more ip addresses or some dns names you
still had to go to the middleware team
to get new middleware
queues
etc etc there was still a central devops
team if you wanted a new jira project or
if you wanted a new pipeline built on on
a jenkins server so
it still
is a broken model from my point of view
and if you if you look at the devops as
a service model where the cloud-based
model where you we look at as ops is
more as an sre site reliability engineer
the google model or you can call it a
devops engineer you can call it a cloud
engineer
these people
now the the sres or the cloud engineers
they need to know all of those things so
they need to know how to spin up
databases
and rds or they need to know how to how
to create your own networks in route 53
etc etc so
another thing i talk about often in the
talks is if you're in if you're in any
of those smaller blue circles
really you should be looking for a new
job or reskilling yourself because
the the role of a dba the role of a
network admin again those roles i think
in five ten years will be gone in the
enterprise
because everyone is moving to the cloud
and and
this role this idea of a site
reliability engineer they're going to be
that's the role of the future the people
that can can do all of this stuff in an
automated way and we talked about
automation a lot tonight with terraform
that can spin all this stuff up um there
that's the role that you're going to
need in the future
so really i think i probably nailed that
on almost five minutes
20 minutes um
so that's really what i want to talk
about really the you know that
the real change i i spent five years
trying to get devops to work in a large
enterprise and really struggling
and i you know now that i'm out of that
environment and working with clients
that are very much cloud native
it's just a whole you know the light
bulb's gone off wow this is really the
power of devops this is really where
what we were meant to achieve five years
ago and really struggled to achieve and
i think so i think that's that's the
that's the future
thank you
you